hello everyone and welcome back to some
more uh chess and some excellent chess
news after that story excuse of a game
that I played it is time to see how a
true Master of the of the art wields the
pieces it is ding luren versus Shang Leu
from the Chinese Chess Championship 2012
so 11 years ago it was played uh and
before we check out the game we do have
some news from the Tata still tournament
that will take place in January of 2024
uh like the title suggests Magnus
Carlson will not be playing as I know a
lot of you guys were very much looking
forward to Magnus facing ding in a
classical game uh so sort of for Magnus
to play against a world chess champion
in classical chess uh but he will not be
playing on their official website it
says that Magnus has some other plans
and that it coincides with some of the
other tournaments that he will be
playing so that's all uh we know in that
regard but we do know who will be
playing so let's check that out before
we check out this excellent game and it
it really is a masterpiece so uh you
know I'm sure you guys will enjoy it uh
these These are the players who will be
playing in the Master's Edition as you
know Tata still has the master section
and the Challenger section so in the
master section you will have world
champion ding Len ala will be playing
Yan pones yanish giri GES PR makulu we
abdat v guti y f Forest Alexander
donchenko as he won the previous
Challengers uh uh previous edition of
the Tata steel Challenger so he gets
seated into the master section this year
then you have Max vadam and women's
world champion jjun I'm very much
looking forward to her her games against
all of them as I imagine she will uh she
she she she will take quite a few points
uh quite a few important points uh so
we'll see how much damage can she do H
and in the Challenger section we uh have
three women har naali D andelina rubar
and some of the famous names from the
Chess World like Anon corov H stean
Mustafa Sal Salam Jam Santos Latasha irn
Lami Leon luk menona Daniel dardam mon
Andrea Mazi leam fre and Stefan Bela uh
so those are the challengers and now
let's check out this game so ding has
the white pieces and he opens with Pon
uh sorry with Knight to F3 and the
reason why it says 2500 plus is uh this
is ding's actual rating that he had at
the time he played this game game uh in
um round five I believe of the of the
Chinese Chess Championship 2660 but I
have no idea what shu's um uh rating was
so I imagine it's over 2500 so that's
why I put it there but yeah we have
night2 F3 Knight to F6 Pawn to C4 and
now Pawn to E6 the ainur defense against
the English we have Pawn to D4 Pawn to
D5 the Queen's Gambit declined and now
Knight to C3 we have captures and now
Pawn to E4 we have Bishop to B4 and now
Bishop captures on C4 so this is the
Vienna variation all been seen before
nothing new here Knight captures on e4
preparing to capture on C3 and of course
castles in the style of um all the great
attackers that played this before D
Knight captures and C3 B captures
attacking the bishop and now Bishop to
E7 for those of you who are wondering I
will show what happens if you capture
the pawn uh black resigns why black
resigns well because white will just
play Rook to be one and it's very hard
to play this of course you will not
resign you will play maybe even 20 30
moves but your position will be terrible
for example you Castle uh Queen to D3
attacks the bishop okay you move the
bishop now Knight G5 threatens Checkmate
you have to play G6 now now Queen to H3
threatens Checkmate on H7 you will have
to play H5 and now G4 and Black's
position falls apart completely like we
can even throw in some fun lines like D5
open up the light squore Bishop here D
captures an E5 and Bishop Bop captures
on G4 looks very good for black but
Queen to E3 and again black resigns uh
what do you play let's say you play
Knight to C6 Knight to H7 comes even
though E6 was also uh possible Knight to
H Knight to H7 is just wonderful uh it
opens up the queen to come to the H6
square and even if you capture doesn't
really help Queen H6 check you go here
now you capture here because the F Pawn
is pinned king h8 queen H6 check uh you
go here uh and now after lights Bishop
G5 you attack the queen queen moves and
then you go Bishop here and Checkmate
the black king so this is only one of
the possibilities why you don't capture
this Pawn uh if you were wondering so
Bishop act to E7 and now Knight to E5
okay pretty standard Square for the
Knight we have castles and queen to G4
preparing Bishop to H6 to put pressure
on that G7 pawn pawn to C5 and now
Bishop to H6 okay threatening Checkmate
you have to defend Bishop to F6 and now
Bishop to D3 and uh look look at this
now Rook to E8 and here Dean played Pawn
to F4 and it is now as of move 13 that
this position has never been reached
again but I would just like to point out
uh this was played in 2012 and 10 years
after this game was played nuo salimova
actually had this position against L
Babu uh in in a tournament and she
played Queen to E4 which is uh in fact
the second strongest move by recommended
by the engine the move F4 is the top
move uh and uh the G uh their game ended
in a draw so salimova was not able to
take the full point with with Queen to
E4 but ding played Pawn to F4 which is
uh much much scarier even though it
doesn't threaten Checkmate right away
but it opens up the uh the path for The
Rook to attack the black king and you'll
see just uh how potent this is now is
there already a threat in the position
due to this F4 move yes there is black
is actually in great uh danger of being
checkmated let's say we play A6 just to
show you what happens play A6
immediately Bishop captures on H7 King
captures now Bishop captures on G7 what
do you play here okay you could get
checkmated very easily so you have to
capture the bishop Bishop captures on G7
Queen to H5 check King to G8 and now
Queen captures on F7 with check King H7
and now you see why Pawn to F4 Rook to
F3 with an Unstoppable Rook to H3 and
that's it black would resign here so uh
after F4 you cannot allow this you have
to play Pawn to G6 which is what shangu
played and now comes Bishop captures and
G6 D happily starts sacrificing pieces F
captures and G6 Knight captures on G6 H
captures and queen captures on G6 uh the
King has to move somewhere if you block
with the bishop uh of course it's
Checkmate so you have to play King to h8
it is the only move and now Bishop to G5
this is how ding clears the H file for
the for for his Rook Bishop captures on
G5 and now although you could go for The
Rook lift uh there's really no defense
here uh for some reason being first
captured on G5 uh Rook to E7 was played
and now Queen to H6 with check uh if you
block with the with the Rook of course
now it's just Checkmate uh check with
the Rook on f8 Queen captures Queen
captures this is Checkmate so after
Queen to H6 King to G8 was played and
now Pawn to
G6 uh not not much to be done here
Knight to D7 was played and now Rook to
F3 preparing to double up on the f file
Knight to f8 and now Rook a to F1 we
have Knight captures and G6 trying to
give up the Knight but not rushing
anything just Rook to G3 uh Rook to G7
ding played Rook captures on G6 and he
was in this position un move 24 uh the
changlu resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here uh really
you can defend Maybe for One More move
like Queen D7 but then the other Rook
comes into the attack and that's it you
you haven't even developed your queen
side uh whatever you play Just Rook G3
and that's it yeah you're going to
capture or white will capture on G7
doesn't really matter king f8 queen to
G8 will be Checkmate so incredible
incredible attacking game by ding Len
really something that belongs in a chess
book on you know in how to attack chap
chapter and uh yeah I thought it I
thought it was very interesting that the
position was reached once again 10 years
after the game was played by salimov and
L Babu and it seems that as the top move
was missed uh neither of them were aware
that this game was already played so
really really funny stuff uh but yeah uh
ding won not just this game but the
entire tournament ding was the 2012
Chinese Champion here are the standings
he won by by a full point margin uh
ahead of Yu yangi and uh he did not lose
a single game five wins zero losses and
six draws so a very very good stuff uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it we are in great expectation
of what will happen once ding returns in
the arena once he faces all of these
great players in classical because now
he's not even number three they have him
listed as number three on the Tata still
website he's currently number four on
the live ratings as he car overtook him
uh yeah been been quite a while since
the world champion was not ranked number
one in the world and uh this will be uh
I yeah this will be the first time that
Magnus is not participating in the Tata
Ste since 2014 and the second time in
the last 20 years so yeah quite quite um
interesting uh but yeah once again
really hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank Amed El halabi David
gasparin saru desert S software and ajs
3tb for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day